[Music]
hi everyone I'm Jenny
I'm from the app partnership team at
Google Play so on a daily basis I speak
to app developers about their challenges
and their goals they tell me that
they're trying to get more users to
subscribe they're trying to get more
users to discover features within their
app the developers I talk to as well as
everyone else in this room you optimize
products in order to better influence
how your users behave and so for me it
really makes sense that if you want to
better optimize for user behavior we
should understand a bit more about
behavioral insights
it just makes complete sense so later on
you're going to hear from Sammi who's
the CEO of the fabulous and the fabulous
is an app that helps people build this
better daily habits he'll share how they
store remarkable growth in user
retention as a result of applying
behavioral economic principles to their
app so in my job as a business
development manager I've spent the last
year immersing myself in the fields of
behavioral economics gamification and
product psychology and I'm sure people
in this room as well as on the
livestream recognize quite a few of the
books on this on this virtual bookshelf
here so we have looks like nudge hooks
predictably irrational and there's so
many great principles within all of
these books that app developers can be
applying to their apps today and so you
don't have to be behavioral scientists
to understand what your users want you
just need to get a feel for some of the
principles in these books son
experimenting and see what works for you
so today's session will really act as a
reminder because I'm sure a lot of you
applying similar principles already and
what I'm going to be sharing with you
are ways that you can address your users
needs better in ways that save
yourselves time and money so to make
this session as actionable as possible
for you what I want you to do is to keep
in mind one key user behavior that
you're trying to optimize
is in your own app this could be
purchasing a subscription inviting a
friend to the app or patek or perhaps
getting more people to return to app
after that initial onboarding phase so
hopefully everyone here has that
behavior in mind so keep it in mind
throughout the rest of the of the
session so now what I want to do is
introduce you to three steps inspired by
behavioral insights that you can follow
to make this particular desired action a
reality many companies tend to focus on
step 3 which is all about trying to
boost user motivation when actually I
think time and money could be better
spent by focusing on step 1 which is
identifying the barriers in the first
place and so when I talked about step 3
then it's about often developers focus
on costly reward schemes and loyalty
schemes so instead let's start with step
simplifying the behavior so every
decision we make requires overcoming
barriers of some kind they think about
everyone in this room today the fact
that you've decided to attend IO perhaps
you have to overcome huge distances to
get here you have to debate over whether
the cost of the ticket was worth the
price maybe you had loads of it a
commitment that you have to also think
about committing to but instead you're
here today so why haven't more users
carried out that one specific behavior
that you've identified a few moments ago
again let's think about it could be it
takes too much time for them to complete
that action perhaps the purchase that
involved is too costly or choosing to do
it among other choices just requires too
much mental effort and so we can
simplify this by identifying these types
of barriers to behavior and removing
them so the food delivery eat sorry the
food delivery app just eat knew that
they would get more successful repeat
transactions if their users safe payment
details during the checkout flow now via
Google Analytics they identified that
many users just went doing this and
while this data tells us that what it
doesn't necessarily tell you the why it
doesn't tell you why users weren't doing
this so
what they had to do was actually conduct
usability tests and by taking this
approach they found out that many users
had certain emotions that you just can't
identify it in data for example some
users were concerned about the security
of digital payments while others simply
didn't want to take that extra step of
clicking save payment details so after
identifying these barriers just
simplified the act of saving the payment
details by firstly making the last used
card the default payment option for any
future transaction and this is really
important here because default is
extremely powerful we tend to follow the
path of least resistance so when
defaults make sense they're a really
great way of overcoming that barrier to
act secondly just the prioritized
partnerships with trusted payment
providers to reduce security concerns in
those users and again even if you're not
currently running usability sessions the
play console offers some really great
tools to help you identify your users
pain points for example you can analyze
real user reviews with the topics and
benchmarks analysis features so
decision-making is impacted by the
number of choices offered which is
something Sammy will talk about a bit
later on and how they tackle that in the
fabulous but it's also impacted by how
those choices are presented to the user
but now I want you to take a look and
glance at this upsell flow from the
recipe apps simple feast so they're
offering the user three choices the
monthly the yearly and the forever so
I'd love to get a show of hands here in
this room who think they're trying to
get more people to purchase a monthly
plan no hands what about the yearly plan
pretty unanimous and how about the
forever plan okay there's a few hands
there so the answer is the yearly plan
because this is actually the best value
plan for their users and what they did
was they applied for different
behavioral concepts and in order to aid
this decision-making
so firstly they leverage social proofing
this is seen across so many different
apps now what's most popular what and
most of the other users doing and this
type of information is really great for
users when they're uncertain in any way
about what they need to do next
secondly they've called out the yearly
plan in a very different color so really
helping to emphasize the annual plan as
the preferred choice thirdly for the
yearly plan they frame that price at a
monthly price this is a more digestible
and easy way for us to understand what
is the actual cost and it helps minimize
that barrier of the perceived cost to
the user and lastly is the introduction
of the forever plan while some users may
be straightaway willing to pay that much
money is actually strategically added
there to help make the yearly plan C
more reasonably price this is often
known as the decoy effect and so overall
these four different techniques really
help to simplify that decision for the
user and make sure that it's more likely
that they're going to choose the yearly
plan and that's actually what the simple
fee SAP saw so we've covered some
tactics to simplify the behavior you've
identified the barriers and so what
we're going to do now is to move on to
step two or three which is all about
triggers so it's important to place
powerful and actionable triggers at
relevant moments in fronts of engaged
users these triggers could be in app
messages email campaigns or of course
the hugely popular push notification and
I'm sure everyone here would love to
achieve a 300% uplift in push
notification open rates so let's find
out
find out now how the language learning
at bouzu' achieve this busuu applied the
behavioral designer near iOS hooks model
to their push reengagement campaigns the
first step in the model is this trigger
and if you take a look the push
notification serves as the external
trigger something that's prompted by the
developer to get the attention of the
user now what's important here is that
this external trigger aligns with the
user's internal trigger of curiosity it
message as a question it gets them
thinking about a word that they've
already learned and as well as this an
important tactic that bazoo use is they
never send the same messaging twice and
I'm sure many of you here tend to get
the same daily reminders the same
prompts every single day and you get
bored of it and you tend to swipe it
away without actually reading it so that
importance of variable messaging is
crucial so step 2 the user takes action
and then clicks through to complete the
quiz and hopefully the answered the
question correctly if they do the third
step is the reward and so they receive a
well done message a simple reward for
improving their language learning skills
and so all of these different steps
together lead to that investment because
this model helps them increase their
memory strengths so in this forever
aligns their apps to their core goal as
well even better this investment
increases the chances of the user
engaging with the app of their own
prerogative without needing that
developer trigger to remind them to
re-engage with the buzu app so for more
best practices on push notifications and
other tools for success
don't miss this upcoming talk by my
colleagues Nico and Gina on this stage
at 1:30 p.m. today so where appropriate
another strategy to ensure your triggers
are as powerful as they can possibly be
is scarcity now when something's
available in limited times or is very
limited time or limited quantities we're
prone to value it more because we have a
fear of missing out on it and so go pace
go back to that behavior you identified
it earlier what can be made scarce that
can make more users likely to take that
decision to act so I'm going to show you
an example now of how the health and
lifestyle app live some wanted to
increase the number of subscriptions
that uses subscribers that users
purchased on day one throughout the
onboarding flow so what they did was
they offered a starter kit that was
messaged as today only now this was
available it was an exclusive starter
kit and it was
only available to people who subscribe
at that moment and this add-on increased
subscription conversion by 15% so it's a
hugely powerful way of helping to make
people act sooner so you've thought
about we thought about how we can
simplify the behavior how we can make
sure our triggers are in the right
places and they're as powerful and
persuasive as they can possibly be
so our final step is to ensure that our
users are motivated and really want to
take the desired actions this is one of
the hardest elements to influence and I
would encourage focusing on boosting
motivation for behaviors where users
maybe aren't already sufficiently
engaged with the app so before we dig
deeper into motivation let's just
discuss the fact that there are two
broad types of motivation that we should
think about so there's intrinsic
motivation where the act of doing
something itself is the reward and then
there's extrinsic motivation so you can
think about this in terms of maybe
offering incentives if someone's doing
something just to get the resulting
benefit of that out of the outcome that
is something that extrinsically
motivated us so games are in many ways
the ultimate motivational product after
all many people here and I'm sure on the
live stream as well you've all spent
hours of your lives playing with these
games especially when they're
successfully engaging you so I'm sure
many people here today as well
understand that there's a lot of
research out there about why games are
so powerful and it goes back to this
idea that it's creating this genuine
level of engagement when it taps into
our intrinsic motivations so again the
act of playing the game is the reward
itself so what I'm going to do now is
share with you a four-step framework for
intrinsic motivation this was created
it's essentially as some of them summary
of two different motivational theories
and this was created what is called the
ramp framework is created by Android
matured game and this will really help
any app developers who are thinking
about different techniques that can help
foster intrinsic motivation
in their app so relatedness is the first
step of the ramp framework relatedness
is all about building social connections
feeling part of a community and have an
belonging to a community as well an
example in a game with the collaborating
with real and virtual friends to
complete a mission the second step in
the ramp framework is autonomy so this
is all about making sure your users have
the freedom to make their own choices
and decisions and not feel like someone
else is controlling them in any way an
example in a game would be exploring a
virtual universe or customizing an
avatar to your exact liking the third
step is mastery so mastery is this drive
within everyone all of us to keep
progressing keep improving our skills
and a gamer might spend hours perfecting
their particular skills in order to
level up or complete a mission and the
last step in ramping up your users to be
motivated to act is this idea of purpose
so this is the drive to add value to a
cause larger than ourselves so when in
doubt adopting techniques that tap into
your users needs one of these four core
mo intrinsic motivations is going to be
a great way of ensuring that so we're
now going to dig into some examples of
how app developers are tapping into
these four intrinsic motivations and
also look out for a future blog post on
the Google Play dev medium publication
where I'll be deep diving into this in a
bit more detail as well so game elements
in and of themselves do not create
engagement but when these elements
appeal to what intrinsically motivates
us they have a better chance of creating
that and so I want to now talk you
through catch of English this is a
language learning app they've obsessed
over the use of game elements within
their app and you can see they've had
some really great success they have a
seven-day retention rate of forty five
percent which is on a par with RPG games
and I'm sure many app developers in this
room would love to have a retention of
almost 45 percent so let's now look at
the two techniques that they've used and
the intrinsic motivations that these
that these
tap into so within the app they have
study groups functionality these study
groups collaborate together to help each
other learn the language and this taps
into our desire for relatedness so to
have connections and just support others
now an interesting twist here is that
the study groups together can then
compete with each other and again
competition on a leaderboard that's a
really classic way of trying to tap into
our desire for mastery we want to keep
improving and get better and ideally be
better than our peers so as well as this
the app itself has some really exciting
visual and audio cues and they're
created in such a way that they help
reinforce progress as the user is going
through the app and learning English so
various studies suggest that altruistic
behavior releases endorphins also known
as the helpers hi so giving your users
the opportunity to help others no matter
how indirectly can really tap into their
drive for purpose the yoga app you gaya
really cares about getting more users to
attend their online live classes and so
what they did was they ran an a/b test
with this in that messaging here and
essentially what they're asking is if
you attend this live class we are going
to donate money to charity and in fact
this actually gave them a nine percent
uplift in class attendance and also
goal-setting goes hand in hand with our
desire for mastery and I'm sure many app
developers here are helping their users
reach new goals and so I'm going to now
talk through two different examples of
app developers who are using these types
of game elements and seeing great
success in terms of user retention so
the hiking out few Ranger they have
allowed users to sign up for in-app
challenges to hike more to cycle more
and when they did some analysis the
users that had signed up for these
challenges were actually four times as
active within the view Ranger apps than
those who haven't there's also the smoke
free app now they did an a/b test
offering 50% of you
is daily missions and the other 50%
didn't get access to any daily missions
and what's really amazing here is that
the users who saw the daily missions
within the app where twice as likely to
quit smoking after three months so
really powerful motivational stuff there
and so I want to take a step back now
think back to that user behavior you had
identified earlier
are you using rewards to effectively
drive this I'm going to now share with
you a hierarchy of reward this is
devised by the gamification consultant
Gabe nikuman and it helps to suggest the
order of rewards and how costly they are
or how powerful they are at driving
loyalty and retention and so you can see
at the very bottom of this is stuff
stuff is things like cash gift cards
freebies so why is this the least
powerful when so many of us offer
discounts and freebies to try and
incentivize people and one of the
reasons could be that they neglect what
genuinely motivates us if you go back to
the idea of the ramp framework
relatedness autonomy mastery purpose
getting these one-time rewards doesn't
necessarily tap into that long term and
again while money and cash can be
sufficient to drive short-term behavior
change it can very quickly lose its
power because people quickly come to
expect the reward every time they take
that particular action and often you
have to give more to get them to be
motivated to act the second time so what
I would suggest from this slide is
rewarding your users with more
meaningful rewards so if we look at
status how can you make your most
engaged users still like VIPs what are
the different perks that they can get
that other users might not and then if
we think about access what are the
features within your app that maybe are
exclusively accessible to certain users
and that could be a more powerful way of
engaging them and actually keeping them
retained for longer so I'm sure many of
you in the audience again developers and
you know that game elements as I said
before do not in and of themselves
create engagement so I wanted to leave
you with a cautionary tale so points and
badges
they're great however if they don't
genuinely map to what really motivates
your users and if they don't symbolize
hard-earned achievements then they're
not going to sufficiently motivate users
and if anything what they might actually
do is make them feel like they're being
bribed to act in some way and this can
be to user frustration so take a look at
this Play Store app rating of a
particular developer when they
implemented a points-based system they
quickly saw a dramatic decrease in the
average rating because even though
they'd implemented the elements
themselves they haven't necessarily
connected it to what motivated those
users so you thought of the behavior
change you wanted to see in your users
we've talked about how you can simplify
the behavior how you can trigger and
then also how you can connect that
behavior to something they find
intrinsically rewarding so I'm now going
to hand over to Sammy who will reveal
how the fabulous app successfully drives
behavior change not just within their
app but also within the users everyday
lives thank you thanks Jenny
hi everyone so I'm the co-founder and
CEO of fabulous pebbles is an app that
helps you build healthy routines into
your life
we are incubated at Duke University at
the Center for advances insight which is
a lab led by Dan Ariely
professor of behavior economics and the
author of the book predictably
irrational so I'd like to frame this
presentation around this framework that
we have developed as a lab that could
help you make better decision in your
app so first of all think about the
behavior what's the exact behavior that
you want your user to achieve then think
about the barriers what are the elements
that could prevent your user from
achieving this behavior and finally
think about the benefits what do I gain
once I achieve that behavior so let's
quickly jump into one example this is
the first screen that you use it to get
when you open fabulous and as you can
see looks pretty good
let's get Sabbath what's your most
important health goal right now then you
can choose to feel more energized to
sleep better
look spit you out but there is one big
problem with this screen only you just a
few seconds to think it out so the
problem was the screen was the question
that we were asking what's your most
important health go right now
so when user reduce they started asking
themselves all sorts of questions can I
make the wrong choice can I change my
opinion later what if I want to change
my goal so one simple change that we did
is just asking them which goal would you
like to start with and now we are giving
them the permission to change their
minds later and this has uplifted the
unburden completion rate by 15 percent
so we wanted to go even further than
this and we started limiting the options
as well like providing them with the
default option and this again has
increased their attention on day one so
hesitate your user is using your app and
he's asking himself all sorts of
questions all the time can I put my
credit card information is it secure
enough so try to answer all these
questions for the user try always to
provide the answer so that the user
doesn't feel frustrated because
otherwise if he saw Sampson herself too
many questions
he will just close the app so to tell
you a little bit about fabulous in Samos
we have aim to help you build the
morning routine and in our opinion this
is the good morning routine you wake up
you drink water you exist such a little
bit and then for some people use each
great breakfast in order to get you to
do this this is how we use it to do it
this is the Oldham boarding so you would
get to the screen where you have all
these habits and then everything else is
hidden out and you need to start on
drink water so we were forcing the users
to do this and I have to tell you they
were really frustrated about this they
thought that we were forcing them they
even sent us this kind of thing L you
betrayed my trust when I had great
expectations for you well how can we
solve this let's go back to these ideas
of behavior economics let's first start
with the behavior what's the behavior
that you're trying to achieve feeling
more energized well that's not the
behavior actually that's the outcome if
you want to think about the behavior
think about the exact set that your
users need to take in our case it's
waking up in the morning reaching out to
my bottle of water and then drinking
water and taking some time to feel great
the behavior is not the outcome and then
let's get to the second step the
barriers I want to drink water or I
don't want what are the barriers so we
conducted the user survey and these were
the three main obstacles I'm not
convinced that I need to drink water I
want to drink water but I don't have
water at reach or I'm just not very
committed let's try to solve this this
is the new embodying if the new
embodying instead of asking you to drink
water we start by asking you a few
questions do you want to build the habit
of exercising in the morning some people
might say yes some people might say no
then do you want to build the habit of
eating great breakfast in the morning
saying some people might say yes some
people might say no and then we ask you
the most important question for us do
you want to drink water in the morning
so this seems very easy related to the
tea all the goals just drinking water so
even if I said no to the two other
questions I'm going to say yes almost
99% of the people are going to say yes I
want to drink water in the morning and
in this case it was your choice actually
it was something that you choose to do
it's not as forcing this on you now
let's think about the second barrier I'm
not very committed I don't feel very
committed to this well what you can do
in this case is using what we call in
behavior connects implementation
intention which is simply asking the
user do you commit to drink water
tomorrow and you can even enhance this
effect by using what we call active
choice active choice means that you're
going to frame the yes question as
something very positive for your user
like I want to drink water and feel
great about myself and then you frame
the negative answer or something not
that good I don't want to drink
I don't care about my house so here's
another way in which you can do this as
you know we're all trying to get our
users to avoid their fans and generally
we would ask them please invite your
friends to our app it's something really
great will make us happy but jelly users
will just run away so another way of
doing this is first of all by stating
the benefit if you invite your fans to
fabulous you are much more likely to
complete your habits and then second of
all let's use the active choice so here
we providing them with three choices two
of them are positive one is negative one
of them is I'd like to invite my friend
to join me on this journey I want to
invite my friend to monitor me on this
journey and then the third choice is
I'll do it on my own a little bit
narrative actually so always answer this
question for the user what is it in for
me what do I gain out of doing this
action always provide the benefits go to
the copy of your app and state
everything as benefit not as goal sort
as objective but as benefits for the
final user now has the bonus one you can
get your users to commit even more by
using what we call a commitment contract
which is simply asking the user to come
into a place and time in which they are
more likely to accomplish this behavior
and then you would ask them to sign up
this with their name this is called the
commitment contract now let's think
about the next barrier well I want to
drink water but I just don't have water
at reach if you think about your users
they are much more likely to come into
your app when they first open the app or
when they just have completed one my son
so this is the best time for you to ask
for even more engagement in our case
after they commit we're going to ask
them would you like to as to send as a
reminder tonight so that you put your
water bottle by your bedside this is
beneficial for the users so they are
really likely to say yes if you are a
finance app this could be the right
moment to ask them to set up automatic
saving if you are google photo this is
the right time to ask for auto backup of
your pictures so think about one action
in
your app that could really lead to much
more engagement think about ways to make
it automated and then ask the user to
commit to this on high points either on
the onboarding or just after they
successfully complete the milestone
within your app so now let's get to the
third part the benefits part what do I
gain out of doing all of this well this
is an interesting one because of course
it's changing for one up to the next if
you our weight loss app it's very easy
to know it's very easy for the user to
know that they have gained it's
something they will just weight them
first one weekend and they would see if
this has been beneficial or no so in the
case of terrible sense we didn't have
that we thought about this idea so each
time that you complete your habits we're
going to ask you to take some time to
celebrate to feel good about yourself
you need something tangible to provide
for the user after a few days of usage
so that they in stand that they're
gaining something out of your app and
here is a good way to think about it
let's suppose that I keep using your app
for few months how's this going to
transform my life
now take all these benefits and make
them in median and cell length tell the
user this is what you're gaining on
every step of the way so pays it we have
now applied the three tenants of
behavior economics first of all we start
to do the outcome we want the user to
feel more energized and from there we
got the exact behavior that we need to
apply I want to wake up and reach out to
my bottled water and then we conducted
the user survey to know about the
barriers and some people are not
committed enough in this case we use
what we call the implementation tension
in order to get them to commit some
people didn't have water at reach so we
use it the active choice idea in order
to get us to send them a gentle reminder
that same night for them to put water
bottle by the bedside and then we have
provided them with the tangible benefits
by asking them to celebrate for a few
minutes their achievements hope this has
been useful Thanks and back to Jenni
thank you very much
so I want just to recap if you go back
to that one key behavior you identified
at the beginning of this talk I really
hope that you found something inspiring
from both mine and Sammy's session and
that you already have great ideas of how
you're going to implement these into
your own app and so once you have done
that I'd love it if you could share with
us your app techniques via twitter using
the hashtag app engagement and to keep
in touch with us about Google Play in
general as well please stay up to date
via these links here and as I've
mentioned before the medium comm slash
Google Play dev is another great
resource for best practices so I hope
you really enjoy today's session thank
you so much for listening
and if you have any questions please go
ahead and step up to the mic thank you
[Applause]
[Music]